a
nossa senhora mano
e aí cara transforma como tu já jogador
e
G1
não não não não não não batata Filipe II
[Música]
E aí
hoje eu vou
apresentar a minha arma secreta
coca-cola Light On
em troca de um [ __ ] tá assim ó
e não não funciona
oi olha
[Música]
olha fui para o hotel Onde os dois
Box ou Felipe challenge
[Música]
copos like challenges in
e
os dois carga por ganhamos o vídeo
aí mais muito amor
[Música]
quase para
[ __ ] olha
[Música]
olha
olha olha olha
[Música]
e
olha Então vamos levantar a
[Música]
e olha só Então vai jogar minha vida
todinha que você vai colocando explicar
segundo vamos
mamãe
olha o
a
chegar Um amor
todas
heróis pessoal
também
Nossa senhora